tests are meant to measure progress
towards gaining practical skills or
understanding ideas their purpose is to
show teachers and students what went
right and what went wrong unfortunately
too many times we fail to act upon what
tests find out instead of fixing the
gaps that tests identify students are
pushed through the school system with
poor test results and bad grades the
problem is that if we fail to fill these
gaps school can become years of boredom
and potentially clever kids might lose
faith in their own abilities most
multiple-choice tests for example are
designed to reward guessing instead of
precision and honesty they do not give
us the option to not know with terrible
consequences after the test has been
taken both teachers and students won't
know whether the student got it or just
guessed it right this sends the wrong
signal and we miss the opportunity to
fill knowledge gaps mastery learning an
educational philosophy first proposed by
Benjamin bloom in 1968 offers a solution
under mastery learning students must
achieve a level of excellence which
could be 90% on a maths test before
moving forward if students do not
achieve mastery on the test they go back
to study and then get tested again this
cycle continues until the student gets
it right only then may they move on to
learn the next thing in 2011 the Khan
Academy a nonprofit organization and the
Los Altos School District showed that
great things happen if math students
advance only if they fully understand a
concept six months into the experiment
of passing only students that fully
mastered a concept the number of
advanced math students doubled and 6% of
the weakest group join those at the very
top
what do you think does it make sense to
teach a student who doesn't understand 8
times 3 equals 24 our 1/6 of 24 equals 4
it's almost like saying you don't know
how to swim in a pool what the heck
try and jump into that River enlighten
us with your perspective or share
relevant links on this topic in the
comments below